TRAFFIC.
YOU
THE FLYERS GET A COUPLE  ROOKIE
>> HE WAS NOT EXPECTED TO PLAY
THE AGAIN.
LET'S GET PROOF OF WHAT  LOOKS E
MAKING ALAST
.
>> HE CANNOT WAIT.
HE DELIVERED THAT JOE, HE
FORGOT THE PART ABOUT THE
EAGLES. CHECK
OF LAWSON CROUSE AND  LOST LINE
OPPORTUNITIES WITH A GOOD  OF P.
THEYTHE SECOND.
LADD, BACK TO CENTER, HE GETS  D
OPPORTUNITY.
HERE IS THE E COULD
NOT CENTER.
IT IS LOOSE IN FROZEN FIRST.
IT IS A SCORELESS  SHOT.
THEY GOT ANOTHER STOP IN THIS
COUTURIER GETS A A A
PERFECTLY EXECUTED SPOT IN
HE WALKSSTOP, RIGHT
THERE ON HIS KNEES.
WE HAVE TH FRONT, THAT IS
ANOTHER SAVE BY KAREL TS THE SH,
HE SCORES!
SCOTT LAUGHTON , AND THE FLYERS
HAVE
INSURANCE MARKER  FROM A REALLY
GREAT PASS OFF OF F  AWAY.
THE CAPTAIN HAS HIS FIFTH COUTU
THE